مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم الى هذا اللقاء
الذي نجريه مع مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي السيد جوزف بوريل اهلا
وسهلا بك الوضع في غزه كارثي للغايه كما
يشاهد الجميع في كل يوم في كل ساعه ما
الذي
تفعلونه لمساعده سكان
غزه نحن زدنا الكثير من دعمنا الانسان
لهم
و وايضا لدينا جسر جوي
لنقل المساعدات لهم اضافه الى فرض الضغوط
السياسيه لجعل هذه الحرب تدار وفقا
القانون الدولي نقدم دعم انساني لاهل غزه
ونحاول وقف الحرب لانها تتسبب بالكثير من
الضحايا الضحايا المدنيين ما مصير الرواق
البحري الذي تحدث عنه بعض الاوروبيين لنقل
المساعدات الى
غزه هذه فكره جيده ان
نستبدل الممرات البريه وستكون عمليه اسهل
من الممرات البريه التي تم تحضيرها والتي
تحتاج الى مرور عدد كبير من الشاحنات حتى
الان لم يتم ذلك نحن نحاول ان نتخيل كل
الحلول طبعا غزه ليس فيها ميناء عامل لكن
ممكن ان نضع عوامات تساعد على رسو السفن
هذا سيكون اسهل من الممرات البريه لكن ان
لم يحدث فيجب ان نبحث عن حلول اخرى قلتم
انكم تمارسون ضغوطا سياسيه ما الذي اسفرت
عنه هذه
الضغوط ليس الكثير
ولكن نحن
استطعنا على مستوى مجلس الامن
الدولي التمرير قرار يحث الاسرائيليين على
تطبي تطبيق
وقفات بشكل مستدام وبشكل عاجل هذا تم
اقتراحه من عضو في الاتحاد الاوروبي مالطا
ودعمه كل اعضاء الاتحاد في عضويه مجلس
الامن وهي فرصه لنذكر اسرائيل بان هناك
قرار من مجلس الامن الزامي يجب ان يطبقوه
وفي رايكم ما مصير هذا القرار هل سيظل
حبرا على ورق
قرارات كثيره دوليه تجاهلتها اسرائيل
تماما نعم هذا صحيح كثير من القرارات لم
يتم تطبيقها ولم يتم الالتزام بها لكن هذا
ما نفعله هذا ما نستطيع ان نفعله لكن في
النهايه الضغوط السياسيه من الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومن الامم المتحده و الولايات
المتحده لجعل الحرب تشن وفقا للقانون
الدولي الانساني اسرائيل لديها الحق
بالدفاع عن النفس لكن الطريقه التي تطبق
بهذا الحق يهم ويهم كثيرا وعدد الضحايه
اكثر مما ينبغي وانا قلت في عده مناسبات
ان عزل السكان في غزه وقطع الدواء والماء
والكهرباء عنهم لا يتماشى مع القانون
الدولي هل تعتبرون ان ما تقوم به اسرائيل
هو جرائم
حرب انا لست محاميا ولكن هناك محكمه
جنائيه دوليه ستتولى التحقيق وعده بلدان
طالبت من المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
فتحه قضيه بالتاكيد ما حدث في الحدود بين
غزه
واسرائيل
وحماس يجب ان
يعتبر جرائم حرب لكن ما حدث في غزه يجب ان
يدرس وفقا القانون الدولي وتجمع الادله
انا لست محاميا لكن عدد الضحايا وعدد
الضحايا في صفوف الاطفال على وجه الخصوص
عالي جدا لا لا يبعث على الاعتقاد بان ما
يتم يتم وفقا للقانون الدولي و بالامكان
عمل المزيد وينبغي عمل المزيد للالتزام
بهذا القانون هل موقف الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
ما قامت به حماس في السابع من اكتوبر
جرائم
حرب يس
نعم نحن نعتبر ذلك جرائم حرب لانه قتل
المدنيين بشكل واضح بشكل واضح من دون اي
سبب قتلهم فقط لانهم كانوا هناك ليس لسبب
اخر لكن سيد بوريل قلت للتو عندما سالتك
عن اسرائيل انك لست
محاميا ف كيف كيف يكون هذا الوضوح في
اتهامك
لحماس انها قامت بجرائم حرب وعندما اسالك
عن اسرائيل تقول انا لست محاميا كما يقول
ساسه غربيون كثر ولهذا السبب كثيرون
يتهمونك باز وايه معايير
واضحه كلا ليس لدينا ازدواجيه معايير نحن
نريد ان نستند الى مبادئ في حاله ما رايت
انا شخصيا نعم يمكن ان يرقى ذلك الى مستوى
جرائم حاب لكن مره اخرى انت محق يجب ان
نترك المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه ان تقرر
ذلك نحن نحاول تطبيق نفس المبادئ ونقول
نفس الاشياء المدنيه يجب ان يح بالحمايه
المستشفيات يجب ان تحظى بالحمايه اسرائيل
تقول تحت المستشفيات هناك مقرات قياده هذا
يجب ان يتم اثباته والمدارس يجب ان تحظى
بالحمايه وهذه رسالتنا على الدوام ان
السكان المدنيين الذين هم تحت الحصار
ومحروم من حاجاتهم الانساني هذا ضد
القانون الدولي وقلت منذ اليوم الاول قلت
ذلك واكر وكثيرون يصدقون ذلك وكثير من
القاده الاوروبيين
يطالبون ويطلبون من المنظمات الدوليه وانا
شخصيا احاول ان اؤثر قدر المستطاع لانني
اعتبر ان هذه الحرب تشن
بطريقه تخلق الكثير من الضحايا خاصه في
صفوف المدنيين لكي نعتقد بان القانون ال
دولي يتم احترامه صحيفه اريتس الاسرائيليه
نشرت تقييما امنيا استندت فيه الى تصريحات
اي لها علاقه بالشرطه الاسرائيليه بان
الاسرائيليين انفسهم قد يكونوا قصفوا
المحتفلين في الحفل الموسيقي في السابع من
اكتوبر وخلصوا ايضا الى ان حركه حماس لم
تكن تعلم بوجود هذا الحفل ايه مسبقا اذا
الروايه الاسرائيليه عليها علامات استفهام
كثيره اضف الى ذلك ان عدد القتلى كان 1400
ثم قلص الى 1200 يعني ولا استطيع ان اذكر
كل التفاصيل ولكن هناك علامات استفهام
كبيره على الروايه الاسرائيليه ومصداقيه
هذه
الروايه طبعا هناك الكثير من علامات
الاستفهام في الحروب ولا ما احدا يدري كم
شخصا قتل في غزه هناك كثيرون قتلوا وكم
شخصا يعرف ان الناس وكم قتل في الحروب
الاخرى او في الهجمات التي ارتكبت حماس قد
يكون هناك
ال00
ربما نحن نعلم ربما احسن من قبل من اليوم
الاول ما حدث ونعم انا قرات او سمعت هذه
الاخبار عن تقرير هارس لكن ليس لدي ايه
معلومات يمكن ان اطلعكم عليها هل من حق
الفلسطينيين ان يدافعوا عن
انفسهم انا قلت واكرر
ان امر فضيع واحد لا يبرر امرا فظيعا اخر
ما حصل من هجوم حماس على الكيبوتس
والاحتفال على الحدود كان رعبا لا اعرف
اذا كانت حماه سعرف كان هناك احتفال
موسيقى لا لا اعرف كيف لي ان اعرف لكن ما
يحدث في غزه هو رعب اخر كلاهما امر مرعب
وانا اطلب هذا الرب ان
يتوقف